hi I'm Nicolas a with reason TV and
today we're talking about John Mackey
he's the co-founder and co-ceo of Whole
Foods Market John thanks for talking to
us thanks for having me on Nick this is
a point in time where we have a
presidential election between the two
most disliked and status politicians in
a generation at least the economy is
slow but is also kind of inventive you
are a very high-profile libertarian is
this a good time to be a libertarian or
a bad time to be a libertarian it's a
bad time to be a libertarian in the
sense that the left appears to be
increasingly trying to police correct
thinking correct speech and they they
tend to go after those who do not you
know whether it be on climate change or
on gay marriage it's a real chilling
effect for any kind of freedom of speech
and in that sense it's a bad time it's a
good time in the sense that who knows
were going to happen the Republican
Party they could suffer a meltdown in
this election and and if that happens
then possible change within that party
might be possible serious change for the
first time in a long long time that
could be a libertarian opportunity you
were a supporter of Rand Paul in the
election or in the Republican primary
system what do you think went wrong with
his candidacy
I think it's several factors came into
play one is he was not seen unlike his
father who was seen as an outsider
I don't think Rand was seen as an
outsider any longer he was a senator he
didn't he thought he would get his
father's support and he didn't get it so
I think that was the biggest factor and
then you had this at a time when
terrorism is increasing the the message
that we need to be less aggressive
militarily doesn't it's not playing that
well in in mainstream America who's
scared so that message did not land well
the security message was a problem and
then I don't think his economic message
was which I agreed with I just don't
think
people or that is interested in that
right now so I think his timing might
have been bad and then you had the whole
populace thing with the nativism
movement the Trump has has capitalizing
so much I think he was the outsider
candidate and and Rand Paul is the
insider and just one of many insiders
and was rejected by the by the
electorate what is your thought on Trump
are you is he you know is he plausible
in any way for you as a candidate or as
a as a president I know he's not you're
a successful businessman he is a
successful businessman what do you sense
as his kind of philosophy of business or
of Commerce or of economics and how does
it differ from yours yeah I would say
firstly as he seems to me to be almost a
prototypical crony capitalist meaning he
made donations to both sides of the
political party often times in real
estate you need to get certain approvals
through various government agencies and
you got to be you got to play both sides
of the fence to get deals done he's a I
think Trump sees himself primarily as a
great deal maker and he wrote a book on
it there was a deal so he sees politics
through that spectrum or through that
lens and for him I think he doesn't fit
the kind of entrepreneurial capitalist
that that I feel like that I that I
represent non cronyism creating value
for other people and one of the
interesting things of course is that he
is seen as a capitalist he's seen as a
businessman and yet in a lot of ways
he's he's not really that were good
representative of it talk about Hillary
Clinton yeah because this these are the
choices right one of them almost
certainly is going to be the next
president the United States what do you
worry about under a Hillary Clinton
presidency I mean there seems to be a
compelling evidence that of the Clintons
not being there certainly not straight
shooters they seem to Hillary seems to
be as much as I complained about Trump
being a crony capitalist I think Hillary
falls into that category herself I mean
you just look at the money she received
from all the speeches she's made and
it's it's like a who's who of the
financial sector health care and defense
contractors it's astounding and then you
see the Clinton initiative with a lot of
money pouring in from foreign
governments it's it's disturbing I mean
that doesn't that's a smoking gun it
doesn't necessarily mean that any
bullets were fired but it is concerning
to me to be to say the least plus we
have the record of the Clinton
administration aid in the past and you
had all those pardons granted at the end
it's just it's disturbing I worry about
it but there is a third term out there
at least there a third possibility which
is a gary johnson and bill weld running
as the libertarian party ticket what do
you think of that
I don't know well know Gary and yeah
like Gary is he the perfect libertarian
candidate no but his overall I probably
agree with him on about 90% of this
stuff and that's far higher than I agree
with Hillary or Trump so the interesting
thing there is they're polling pretty
high but when people get in there to
vote I mean I'm going to vote for Gary
Johnson so but when they get in there to
to vote because the OL argument you're
throwing your vote away is such a
powerful argument that they're probably
he's probably going to get fewer votes
than he's polling at the end of the day
but still I mean if the if the
libertarians were to get two or three
percent that would be an outstanding
election cycle for them because and
they've never gotten that much before
they're running in that kind of fat
middle of the where the country really
is that people are generally socially
tolerant and fiscally responsible they
want a government that is less in your
business and you know and can pay its
own bills do you think that that kind of
thinking is actually ascendant I mean
clearly the Republican and Democratic
parties don't give outlets to that kind
of thinking but our is America moving in
that kind of soft I thought so when I
read read you and Matt's book a few
years ago but it doesn't see me playing
out that way I mean the
the nativism that i had no idea until
trump ascended how powerful the nativism
sentiments are because I think that's
the key to understand Trump its native
istic in immigration native istic in
jobs in foreign policy in taxes and
every in every way it seems a very
strong native istic one glossing one of
the interesting things it has really
come out or come into play yet but polls
routinely show that even 50% or more of
Republicans believe in not just in
current levels of immigration but a
pathway to citizenship or legality for
currently illegals and then Democrats
it's a little bit higher so it will be
interesting to see if nativism it
clearly carried Trump through the
primary and then what happens in a
general election your business in many
ways is built on kind of free trade
agreements the fact that you can bring
in goods from all over the world and put
them into one place why does it you know
that a lot of people are ok with on the
right but then when you talk about
bringing it letting people from all over
the world move here what is the what is
the switch that is flipped that makes
that a totally different and much more
terrifying scenario if you study the
history of the United States and I've
studied it very carefully for a long
time always when we're doing immigration
there's whenever there's been
accelerated in immigration American
history there have been race riots and
whether it be the Irish coming in or
Italians or there's always been pushback
against it so it's like our nation can
handle a certain amount of immigration
but when it gets to be too much too fast
then the culture is unable to absorb it
effectively Americanized so to speak and
people become scared and threatened by
it and I think we're in one of those
situations right now plus I think there
is an element of probably an element of
racism in it in the sense that fear of
non-whites and
it's it's theirs I think there's an
element of that in it from a your
business perspective what are the
biggest things holding back economic
growth you know one of the things over
about the past 10 or 15 years average
economic growth has averaged around 2%
or less a year the historic average
since world war 2 is about 3% so that's
a big variance it's a couple of obvious
things most importantly is regulations I
feel like there's almost regulatory war
against corporations in America right
now it's it's the number of regulators
attacking wholefoods is unprecedented in
our entire history and honestly I don't
feel like it's risky for me to even talk
about it because I don't want additional
regulatory harassment that costs our
company tens of millions of dollars and
I feel like that's happening I talk to
other CEOs and this is not just a
wholefoods problem they're all feeling
the squeeze on the regulate regulatory
agencies what is raising them what's an
example of a useless regulation that you
you deal with that you know makes it
harder to deliver you know services and
goods at a good price we're dealing with
a toxic waste issue disposal of multiple
vitamins that have selenium in them they
have a little few micrograms and that's
been classified by the EPA as a toxic
waste
what is selenium selenium is a is a
trace mineral that we need nutritionally
but only in very small little amounts so
when we're when we get what do we do
when multiple vitamins are returned to
us for some reason there are
dissatisfied we take it back well
because it a selenium in it we can't
just throw that in the landfill of which
of course we did we just throw it in the
trash that now has to be disposed of as
a toxic waste well I mean that sets up a
whole toxic waste disposal system for
vitamins that people are eating ok I
would say that's seems like kind of a
nonsensical regulation but there's all
types of employment regulations very
increasingly difficult the United States
to be able to terminate anyone
particularly anyone that's in a
protected class the amount of paperwork
that you have to track and even then
you're probably still going to get sued
and very like illegal either lose you'll
have to settle to play
devil's advocate people would be like
well it's good you shouldn't be able to
fire people quickly especially people in
protected classes because they're in
protected classes because they need
protection I disagree I mean employment
is a voluntary exchange that occurs
between individuals who are looking for
work and employers are looking to hire I
mean should people be able to quit
whenever they want to or or should we be
able to force them to continue to work
for us I mean I firmly believe that it's
not in the best interest of any employer
to fire people arbitrarily
and this is what's usually held up abuse
and does that occasionally occur of
course it does that doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to set up the system
so that employers are constantly being
incented or harassed if they do
terminate someone because if again why
would they want to terminate a good
worker they wouldn't and but yet they're
constantly seen as guilty of doing
something wrong and then they have to
prove their innocence when they
terminate someone but that doesn't go on
the other side of the equation if
somebody terminates or resigns because
they found a better job or or they don't
like it or they're racist and they don't
like the company who knows but there's
no so it's to me a double standard talk
about the 365 stores that you're
starting to roll out how are those
different than a traditional Whole Foods
Market and what are you hoping to a to
accomplish with that the stores are
smaller than a traditional Whole Foods
Market
they have only about a quarter of the
number of products that you might have
in a whole fort so it's a very curated
product mix and then we were building
these stores for about a third of the
cost of a regular Whole Foods Market so
the capital costs are significantly
lower and then we've restructured this
stores to have far lower labor component
the long and the short of it is is that
we're taking about a what we call basis
points a thousand basis points or ten
whole percentage points out of the cost
structure and that's been passed on to
the customers and much lower prices so a
very low produce prices and very low
center
store prices and we yet we have Whole
Foods Markets kind of prepared foods
selection and our quality standards are
still in effect so we think this is a
very successful format that we're
probably going to have hundreds of these
stores and within not that many years
and will they compete against Whole
Foods Market or do they supplement it or
how does that work there will be some
competition of course there'll be some
overlap and customers but what we found
so far is the cannibalization has been
less than we anticipated that we're
getting a customer in it's more price
sensitive that we were not getting into
Whole Foods Market stores and so the
number of Trader Joe's bags that we've
seen shopping in our stores is
unprecedented is that kind of the direct
competitor for the photos is a direct I
mean in some ways 365 computer Trader
Joe's it can speech with sprouts farmers
markets but of course the main
competitors are the other mainstream
supermarkets like Kroger and h-e-b in
Wegmans but we now have a model a
business model that allows us to be less
expensive and not be under under sold by
anyone and that's a good place to be in
speaking of cannibalization let's talk
about the movie that you've helped
produce at the fork which is done by the
Lisa and John Paul oh the great
documentary filmmakers and it is about
John's kind of move towards veganism or
understanding of animal welfare in the
food production change
well of course John is not a common
vegan is jompa Pollan Lisa Versace or a
married couple and they are Lisa's a
vegetarian John is a carnivore and the
film starts out with a pop Ola
family gathering whether they're eating
what is it it's called the is it the rib
fest the red fescue FS yeah and that
shows that and and then Lisa expresses
our disapproval of that and they begin
this journey into America basically to
see how our animal foods are raised and
what's fascinating about the film is the
film itself is very non-judgmental
and lets the camera do the talking and
it lets every so it goes from some of
the factory farm producers all the way
up to some smaller animal ranchers who
are treating their animals surprisingly
very very well hi so they're all
different grades of welfare treatment
and each in a sense allows each of the
animal farmers or ranchers to give their
own philosophy I mean it's actually
really I found it fascinating because
it's it's a movie it is about a journey
and there aren't villains here or the
the farmers that the factory farmers
aren't treated as poor stupid people who
only care about a buck but they do have
constraints and they voice the time and
time again like I will I will treat my
livestock any way that my customers
asked me to it is fascinating because
their philosophies get articulated and
so the film is remarkably fair it's
unlike some films that might come in
with a real biased point of view and
then said it is a if Michael Moore was
producing a documentary even he would
come in with a bias and then make sure
the film comes out that way this was a
discovery process and and they let these
farms are fair to all the farmers they
all they all get a chance to give their
philosophical product are their farmers
because I was taken by that you know at
various stages as they get closer to a
more kind of animal friendly generally a
higher end price point and stuff like
that but all of the producers pretty
much say some variation of I don't
really have a stake in how I raise my
like what I'm doing is to serve the
customer and if the customer wants
something at a certain price I'm going
to do it in a more industrial way or a
less industrial way are there people who
are ideologically committed to kind of
factory farm
processes or you know treating livestock
in the least thoughtful way I don't know
if ideology is what I would say the
overwhelming driving thing it has always
been in food production is how can we
get cost down just like Whole Foods
Market with 365 is thinking through our
business model how can we take cost down
so we can get lower prices to our
customers that same logic carries for
that's where capitalism works
and here you have the as one of the
James McWilliams says a professor of
history says these decisions that moved
us towards the factory farm system were
hundreds if not thousands of small
little innovations that took us in this
direction of taking cost out of the
system and ultimately the lowest-cost
system is one that has scale and which
minimizes feed inputs and all the other
factors of production and that tends to
be by most dispassionate viewers is
pretty inhumane
who are the animals you are a vegan
yourself correct can you briefly recount
your conversion a little over 13 years
ago
I was at an annual Whole Foods Market
annual meeting force our stockholders in
Santa Monica California we were being
picketed by animal rights activists and
they were disrupting our meeting I was
very happy about that I thought like
they don't there shouldn't even be here
this is inappropriate but I got into
discussion with the activists after the
meeting was over particularly this one
very tiny but passionate young woman
named Lauren or Neely Asst and we began
an email exchange and we were going back
and forth because for my attitude back
then was I don't know why they're
picking on us we're doing more for
animals than anybody else why anything
going after Safeway or Kroger for
example and because as they would say
what we thought you would actually
listen we didn't think they would and I
remember her telling me she said John I
can see that you're actually very
idealistic man you're not like I thought
you would be I think you're not a
typical corporate CEO but when it comes
to animal welfare and animal the way
animal livestock animals are treated in
the United States you're remarkably
ignorant and where she wrote about them
yes and you shouldn't be because you're
running a fairly large corporation and
you sort of it to all of your customers
and employees to know better about these
things so I was taken
back and I realize you know she's
probably right about that I could be
better informed
so that's summer summer of 2003 read
about a dozen books on livestock animals
in America how it evolved practices and
got about midway throughout two hundred
four or five books I thought you know
she's really right I don't know I didn't
know anything and furthermore we got to
do something about it by the time the
summer was over I said I I'm not gonna
eat animals anymore I became a vegan and
from an ethical standpoint and I also
decided you know Whole Foods needs to do
a lot more here so we invited the
activists to work with us as on our team
so to speak and then bring in this
animal scientist bring in the farmers
themselves bring them together into
meetings and let's talk about how we can
develop more hired animal welfare
systems that have higher and so that's
how I converted and that's what Whole
Foods has been doing ever since is there
a point where the you know where you
will from a kind of moral perspective
stop selling animal products or like how
do you how do you square that between
your treating the animals better but
you're still selling them is that
because the customer wants them or where
when does that it was funny I get asked
that question a lot and I suppose
because I'm so closely identified with
the Whole Foods Market brand and people
for the most part don't understand how
corporations work they think quite
incorrectly
that Whole Foods Markets like my company
that I'm like this all-powerful owner
that can do it over I want and but in
fact I founded the company but we're a
very large corporation at this point and
it it I always tell the story that let's
say I wanted to do that
I would not be able to do it if I said
you know what guys I really think we
need to stop selling meat that's just
the right thing to do and so effective
this date I'm issuing a command as the
co-founder co-ceo that we're going to
phase out of meat well everybody would
think it was a joke as they wouldn't
they would laugh and and I'd say no no
no no no I'm very serious about this we
I've seen the light we are going to stop
selling meat at Whole Foods Market and
they would say John you've got to be
kidding you know we can't
you haven't completely ruined the
business I said nevertheless it's the
right thing to do by God we're going to
do it about that time of course the rest
of the executive team would be like what
has happened to John he's like going
crazy but then if I persisted calls
would go to the Board of Directors
they'd say we got to do something he's
about to wreck our business and I would
get calls from the board and they would
say John you know you can this work you
can't do this you're gonna have to back
off on this and I'd say no this is the
right thing to do by god I'm going to do
it well if I continue to persist I would
be removed as a CEO that's just the
reality of the situation that's the way
business sort of works and that's the
right thing for them to do because whole
fees market ultimately ultimately has to
serve its customers and there I like
nothing better than the customers to
vote with their dollars for Whole Foods
Market to stop selling animal foods but
until that vote occurs we're going to
continue to sell them because that's
what they want to buy and that's part of
the function of at the fork right that I
mean you're it's not a preachy movie I
mean it is didactic there's a message
there but it's hopefully raising
people's conscious I really think that
the forks if it has a purpose its to
raise people's consciousness because the
average American has no idea how animals
are raised they don't want to know
there's sort of massive cultural denial
about it I actually think that 100 years
from now we'll look back on the factory
farm era with the same kind of ethical
revulsion that we look back on say
slavery which was obviously completely
morally reprehensible by any standard
and I think this will be seen in a
similar light although I I say that
sometimes people are offended because
they don't they see the the moral
revulsion slavery but they have not yet
opened their eyes to see the moral
reversion of what we're doing to factory
farm animals so this film is an attempt
to nice pg-13 we're not showing the most
horrible stuff because otherwise people
just walk out of the theater we're
giving it in a measured dose and most
important we're showing them that there
are better alternatives so if I had my
way when people finish watching that
film they'd be faced with an ethical
dilemma which is I mean either I'm not
going to eat meat anymore
or I'm only going to eat higher animal
welfare meat that would be the torso
like see people make well the movie is
at the fork and we have been talking to
Whole Foods co-founder and co-ceo John
Mackey thanks so much for talking to us
John
thanks Nick for reason TV I'm Nicolas
ting
you